we begin with breaking news out of the
philippines where a magnitude 7.1
earthquake has hit the north of the
country
the epicenter appears to be the town of
delores in the province of abrah
tremors were felt far away in the
capital city malia which is more than
300 kilometers to the south and train
services have been stopped the us
geological survey says there is no
threat of a tsunami now barnaby lowe
joins me now via skype from manila
barbie what more do we know
uh imran as you mentioned this was
measured at magnitude 7.1 earthquake by
the usgs
but earlier it was measured a little bit
stronger by the philippine seismology
agency at 7.3 now they're revising it to
7.0
uh
in any case it is a strong earthquake
covering a large swath of the country
the epicenter is in the northern
philippines but we are 400 over 400
kilometers away from that and we still
felt the tremor it was pretty strong and
it was also pretty long i felt it for
maybe about a minute um and the movement
was in circles uh really the depth at 25
kilometers this is a shallow earthquake
a tectonic earthquake there's no tsunami
threat as you have mentioned but life
has been disrupted temporarily
in areas that have been affected by this
earthquake obviously
schools and offices suspended in the
northern philippines but even here in
manila
trains have been stopped and so there is
a long queue of commuters
riding the buses here
as
the maintenance operators are checking
the viability of the commuter trains
here in metro manila also office
buildings evacuated they're checking
damages in these office buildings both
private and government
office buildings i've seen
initial photos of the damages there
seems to be extensive
damage in the northern philippines abra
is not a heavily populated not heavily
urbanized province but there are
neighboring provinces and cities that
are heavily populated and heavily
urbanized and major roads have had
cracks
at least one major road is now
impassable due to a landslide and i've
seen homes that have partially collapsed
there was a bell tower a church bell
tower
that crumbled um fortunately so far
there are
no reports of casualty but we will see
we will continue to monitor him
why do we load that live for us from
manila